cheers of celebration in the sewers
canal
and horns blaring as the ever given
finally appears to make a move
for days and despite a multi-national
rescue effort the vessel has hardly
budged
now finally it's been refloated wedged
across the sewers canal the scale of the
problem has dwarfed the machinery
seen as a solution dredgers and diggers
have removed
thousands of cubic metres of sand from
underneath the giant container ship
and a team of at least 10 tugboats has
been trying to dislodge it for days
since it ran aground tankers and cargo
ships carrying oil
gas and grain have stacked up at either
end of the canal
delaying global trade and costing
billions of dollars
every day around about seven percent of
the world's oil trade goes through the
the suis canal um and it can't
any any ship has the choice of of taking
the longer route round
the south of africa takes around two
weeks longer obviously costs more
because of the additional um shipping
costs so ships are having to make that
decision
do they wait um in that queue of of 300
or do they take the longer trip
the crisis is already having an impact
on syria
the authorities forced to announce fuel
rationing as supplies from iran are
stuck
the news coming out of syria is deeply
deeply worrying
the country was already hitting crisis
point with the economic collapse
hitting syria and the daily lives of
syrians and now these
delays to fuel shipments will make an
already bad situation worse
there had been fears an operation would
be needed to lighten the ship
which is 20 000 containers on board
requiring a crane
and other equipment that's yet to arrive
but it appears a flotilla of tugboats
and a higher tide may have deemed that
unnecessary
alexis o'brien al jazeera